mark consuelos
in the beginning of one scene
starts snoring and i don't know what
take they used but there's a moment when
i am holding in laughter so hard that
tears are forming
i will finish what my father began
you're unstoppable
oh my gosh michael it is so good to see
you
here we are a season and a half later
and you have your whole own episode
playing young hiram how did this come
about and how are you feeling about it
oh man you know
it's it's been a dream come true really
i think my dad told me like when we were
doing the first one that they'll
probably want to explore these
characters more and the parents and what
they're up to and you know then a few
years went by and i'm like what did they
lose interest
but then they came then they you know my
dad brought the news back up to me and
said they really wanted me to go for it
and do this whole thing for hiram and i
took like a billion acting classes uh to
prepare for because i'm not aside it was
kind of an important part of it this
time around and you know it was huge and
it was really fun and intimidating and i
think it was the best i had the best
time i've seen the episode it's
absolutely sensational everyone who's
watching this video has just finished
watching it what was the most
challenging part for you when it came to
filming this episode i felt ready for it
like i wasn't it wasn't nerves as much
like i felt totally prepared for it and
then yeah i was working with people i
knew it wasn't like that intimidating
but honestly the action scenes were
really and
hard to do uh the thing that i had a big
fight scene
poor charles actually hit his head on
the car during that and i was mortified
oh god i'm fired i'm fired this is it
and the the shooting scene that was also
pretty hard because a lot of stuff goes
into that there was explosions and
exploding glass and you gotta reset it
and do it again
also you know the big scene where uh
jaime hiram fights with his dad that was
tough i don't like talking to my dad
that way but i think it held the
performance because you know made
emotions it made it feel a little more
real hyrum says a lot of stuff he
doesn't mean to his dad and i think it
helps with the performance because i was
saying a lot of stuff i didn't mean to
my dad this is actually the first time
that we've seen you and your dad on
screen together because your dad was
then playing hiram's dad what was that
like for you to share scenes with your
dad and be honest what did you think of
the mustache it was so awesome i've said
it before it was a bucket list moment
working with my dad and he's a great
person to act obviously they all are but
like dad in particular like brings a lot
to the scene and he he's a good he's a
very giving person to act obviously we
have a lot to work with there i like the
mustache and it was really trippy for me
because his dad my grandfather has a
similar stash so it was really it felt
like i was kind of out acting opposite
my grandfather and at points you know so
you know and also it's accurate because
you know hiram in the comics has a
mustache so this is sort of like a call
back to that i think i actually go by a
different name now
his name is hyrum every gangster has an
origin story
i love the fact that you got to act
opposite charles melton and camila
mendes quite a bit on this episode you
got to share scenes with them a little
bit the first time you were on but what
was it like to really get to act
opposite of them incredible they're both
amazing and super cool people and it was
really funny during the fight scene
charles was like no you could you could
like throw me harder and i'm like no
dude you're actually a giant i i this is
as hard as i can go he thought i was
being easy but i know i'm just i was
shrimpy at the time obviously candy was
awesome and it was really cool you know
it was awesome to see more of hermione
and hyrum because you know we see them
as adults and it's kind of like they're
dark sided and the relationship's gone
south but in the beginning it's so pure
and almost bonnie and clyde-ish how she
like bails him out of prison and like it
was awesome and she helped him come up
with his name like it was just
a backstory like i really loved that is
there anything that you want to tell the
riverdale fans about this episode that
they might not know there's a moment
when obviously hiram's identifying his
father in the morgue
tragic scene but
mark consuelos
in the beginning of one scene
starts snoring and i don't know what
take they used but there's a moment when
i am holding in laughter so hard that
tears are forming
and
i don't i just he i don't know he just
kind of fell asleep under the sheet i
just hear like a low snore
and i i don't know how i didn't lose it
but you know i almost lost it it's not
half bad
you